もうすぐお菓子禁止から
一月の最初に始めて、
２，３，４(ヶ月)
もう3ヶ月お菓子禁止をやってます
はじめしゃちょーです
お菓子禁止してからでもやっぱり
痩せるのが目的じゃないんですよ…　痩せるのが目的じゃなくて、
真の目的は体調を、体の体調を良くしたいというのが目的だったので
結構体は多分結構多少なりとも良くなってるとは思ってるんですけれども
もっと！
俺には！
根本的に直さなきゃいけないことがあると思う
それは何か
そう
普段のご飯
そう！俺、はじめしゃちょーは普段からご飯をつくらない
自炊したくない
だからいつも
どうしてるかって？
SOU！いつもコンビニでご飯を食べてます。
良くない……
非常～によくない！
非常に～よくないんですけれども、
だからねちょっとねどうしようかなと思ってた矢先に
ドンキですごいものを見つけました
今回の商品はこちら！！
ジャージャン！
『おひとりNOODLE MAKER（ヌードルメーカー）』
お一人用なんですね…
♪~
フゥン(´;ω;｀)
お一人用なんだね（泣）
はいっということでこのヌードルメーカー何かといいますと
なんとラーメンを作れるみたいです
名前の通り…
すごいと思います
あのカップ麺はそもそも僕あんまり食べないんですよ
ラーメンは好きだから
よく夜中にねラーメン屋さんとか行って、友達と
ラーメン食っちゃうんで
なのでそのラーメンを食べに行く手間すらも省けちゃう
っていう、もうとっておきのアイテムっすよ
これさえあればもう家で一人で
ラーメンが食えるかもしれませんからね
オープンッ！！！
…あっ…
オープンッ！
読めなくなっちゃった
なるほどなるほど
これは、フタです
本体、電源スイッチ、コード
ハイサイ探偵団
お湯の沸かし方
まずは、水を入れます
なんか水は0.3L~1Lとか、適当で良いみたいですね
沸騰し始めたらインスタントラーメンを入れます
フタをして茹でて下さい
お湯を沸かす作業から始めましょう
よし
よしよしよし
早速、沸かしましょう
GO！